The second way that the differently executing concurrent machines can
communicate is by data conditions. We've already, we've already seen this.
Remember that they occur within square brackets. Okay? And they contain within
them Boolean expressions in which the terms correspond to attributes
of a various classes in the overall system model.
You can think of these data conditions as being continuously monitored.
And that when one of them becomes true, that's like an event were issued saying,
look at me I'm now true, I can take this particular this particular transition.
State charts, in addition, support the keywords in and not in.
What in means is, I'll make this transition if in one of the other concurrent
machines I'm in state whatever x is. So if I say in x and
in the other machine I'm in state x, then I can make the transition. And
similarly from not in. The variables which occur in these expressions,
as I said, come from attributes in the system model. And these attributes
are globally known by all of the concurrently executing machines.